lastly the government didn't build
enough her back but I think Nigel said
something very revealing because he
basically said what mrs. Thatcher you
say you can't buck the market well the
problem about the market in housing
nigel is it doesn't work is not working
it's not working because the large
developers have a stranglehold on the
market and I'm going to do something
about it and you're not it's not working
so we're not building our homes in our
country and therefore here you're right
is an issue of demand and supply there's
not enough supply in our country and
that's what we've got there and the
reality is we haven't done it for a
generation and the next Labour
government will get to grips with it
because it is one of the biggest
priorities our country faces and we are
letting down our young people and we are
letting down our families this
stranglehold Nigel Farage this
stranglehold of the big developers do
you agree I don't disagree that with
that for one moment which is why I want
a Brownsville revolution bed if you have
net migration into Britain running at
300,000 a year that's 300,000 more
people that need somewhere to live and
the point I'm making is that I mean our
plans would be with a brownfield
revolution for 200,000 homes a year but
even that isn't enough unless we cap the
demand side of this equation okay let me
respond to that case yes yes good
there's two things I would say to you
back Nigel but the first thing is that
your plan in relation to migration I
believe we do try and need to try and
get not like net migration down but your
plan this is your plan is to get out of
the European Union now that's your way
of doing it that is a disaster for our
country cuz I is a disaster for jobs
that is a disaster for our economy so
I'm not going to go along with your plan
but let the second thing is this we can
do more for local people when it comes
to housing change this issue of planning
permission planning permission is
granted locally and then local people
find themselves locked out bye-bye to
let landlords them out of the area I say
give councils the powers to set aside
homes for local people in an area
because planning permission is more
likely to be granted and local people
can get homes to live in